[Music]
hey everybody
yeah it's monday yep so we saw this one
last night it's pretty good
it's got my ex-girlfriend in it
which i think is probably the only
reason you wanted to watch it
she doesn't have a huge part in it but
she's like in the first like third of it
yeah
yeah she played her name is marilyn rice
cub she had we went to high school
together
and uh [ __ ] she was a good friend of
me and me and [ __ ] our little
crew you know she's kind of like a
proto-goth girl back in the day
back in trenton and um
she uh went off to drama school she was
in the same drama program i was in then
she goes off to
at the college level and uh she ended up
becoming a comedian for a while and
bidding a bunch of movies and this is
one of the ones that she did
and i was gonna see it anyway because
the guys that i
subscribed to like nerd erotic and uh
midnight's edge and everything said said
good things about this movie
it was being trashed uh like on rotten
tomatoes
by the uh professional critics but the
[ __ ] audience was loving it they were
giving it like 90 something percent and
then the critics were giving it like 40
you know uh just because
i guess because white guy stars in it i
guess i don't [ __ ] know you know what
i mean they don't like no that wasn't
why
well they don't like chris pratt it was
because the only criticism i saw of it
was that they just thought that it was
like derivative they said it's pretty
much just like independence day or
i know but i'm just saying that's really
the only criticism of it
and most of the other like uh even the
reviews that were critical and saying
that was kind of like a ripoff or
whatever
they all said yeah but chris pratt is
really good at it and it's fun and [ __ ]
like that don't listen to them [ __ ]
professional
critics all right that [ __ ]
are too hard on good movies and if it's
like something that would please the gym
you guys know how they are you know how
they are if it's something that would
please a general audience then they got
a poopoo on it oh it's not sophisticated
you know whatever
[ __ ] damn it's a [ __ ] good movie man
i approve
i approve of it um it's uh
kind of like uh like you said kind of
like independence day and
also kind of like uh starship troopers
rolled up into one movie um
although i have time traveling i think i
liked this one better than either of
those
to be honest with you i don't know
because i i did not love independence
day
independence day i thought was mediocre
um
even in those days i thought it was kind
of me yeah the same but i like starship
troopers a lot
yeah i like star trek i like starship
troopers better than independence day
but i think i like this one better than
starship even though the guys who
directed starship troopers were kind of
goofing on it i still [ __ ] liked it
i liked how i read the book too [ __ ]
and i liked heinlein but you know
they didn't like highland you know he
they would they would say he was fascist
or some [ __ ]
it was just a future i don't want to
talk about
about about uh i'm getting getting
sidetracked let's stay on this movie but
yeah you're getting sidetracked
that's that's what i do i clown around
grantham's hammer says the volume is
super low but i haven't changed anything
on it well so i don't i don't know what
to tell you
see what it says it says the same thing
what did i just say
that's you is it low for everybody
i mean no one else said anything yeah so
maybe it's just maybe maybe your volume
checklist
yeah did you try turning it off and
turning it on again yeah
we were he was in the same drama program
with me at trenton he knows mary lynn
marilyn was [ __ ]
awesome she was [ __ ] hilarious uh but
she plays a part in this called nora she
didn't get top billing
but she's got a pretty big part in it um
she's kind of like uh one of the one of
the side characters like one of the more
major side characters you know and um
it's [ __ ]
it's a good movie um takes place
starts off it's what was it christmas
christmas 2022
2022 and they were watching a soccer
game and all of a sudden it just whites
out there's this big
[ __ ] dimension door opens up in the
middle of the soccer field
and a bunch of soldiers run out and
they're saying we're you from 30 years
in the future
we're getting our ass keys kicked by
aliens you we have to start drafting
people from the past
to come back to the future with us help
us fight because we're losing
and if we lose then it's the end of
[ __ ] mankind
so they're taking people from 2022
that fit certain criteria which you find
out they draft them
give them very little training and send
them to the [ __ ] future
to fight these uh aliens
and uh you don't know anything about the
aliens you don't really know much about
them until the end you see them
they're like an alien animal uh
but they're evidently intelligent they
reproduce real fast
they look pretty good yeah i actually
did quite like the uh creature design in
this yeah
they're called white spikes yeah it's
hard to do any kind of aliens that are
original i mean everything's been
thought up and if you ask me the
xenomorphs one of the best aliens ever
[ __ ] made you know
hard to top that heart atop that that
one and the [ __ ] thing
yeah it's hard to top those aliens so
you have to come up with an original
design that's believable
you know and that is kind of and
you know the predator was [ __ ]
awesome too you know how do you beat
that but
they come close well i don't say they
come close they do a good job at coming
up with an alien
i thought the faces of these of the
white spikes were like really good like
really
really scary yeah they got six legs and
tentacles tentacles and they can shoot
spikes yeah
out of their tentacles on the back and
the tentacles are like a tail too
but it it's flat and ends in a little
thing they could open up like a little
little three prong like the demi gorgon
from stranger things
it can grow a poison spike in there and
shoot it out and uh
they're real fast so they can run across
the ceiling and everything it's all cg
but it looks pretty good
um it looked like it's just like a big
budget
kind of 10-pole action movie um
that you would normally see in hollywood
evidently that's what it was supposed to
be but because of covid they just had to
kind of sell it off at a bargain
yeah it's paramount i think and it's i
think it was supposed to premiere
last christmas december 2020. um and
then it got pushed back and then it was
gonna
uh premiere in the theaters like this
july and then they said well
we don't think it's gonna you know do as
well in the theater so they just uh
amazon prime bought it for i think 200
million
yeah yeah if you have amazon prime you
can see it for free
yeah if not you got to pay to see it
it's worth seeing it's worth it
i thought it was quite entertaining yeah
i mean i thought well you know what i
mean it's a
it's kind of like i was expecting you
know a big dumb action movie so i'm just
like okay that's cool with aliens you
know i can
hang with that but it actually wasn't as
dumb as i was uh
as i thought it actually the nice thing
about it was that one i liked the
creature
design uh chris pratt was good i liked
him and like the interaction with his
little daughter
like that little girl was in it was
great and um
i liked that it had humor in it but it
wasn't like
over-the-top stupid like zany humor
right it was a little more
subtle what i liked about it is that
it did have some individual i would call
them
concepts that were kind of gimmicky but
it wasn't too many of them it didn't get
boggled
bogged down the whole time travel
concept that whole gimmick
i thought was great and it wasn't
overplayed that much
sometimes there's too many goddamn
gimmicks in the same movie this one just
used that one
um you know what i'm talking about yeah
and it kept it more believable when you
start adding seven or eight [ __ ]
gimmicks on the damn same movie it's
just
you have to keep these kind of movies
simple if not the story starts bogging
down
the whole thing is just to keep it
rolling and it
the edit was good it just rolled along
you didn't really it had a couple spots
that were kind of slow
but it they had to be there for like
kind of like intermissions
in between big uh action scenes yeah
like big battles and stuff that happened
um
you're going to see a lot of call a lot
a lot of callbacks a lot of call backs
to alien
predator independence day um
[ __ ] what was the one that i told you
starship troopers there's a lot
of callbacks the movie knows what it is
yeah it's not trying to be something
yeah it wasn't trying to be original or
anything like that it was just trying to
be like a big fun right scary action
sci-fi
it kind of was original though in a way
i mean it borrowed a lot from other
movies but just the tone of it
it did have its own i mean it wasn't
generic no way
and like i said i i did actually like
this movie a lot better than i liked
independence day it just stayed within
the theme and the motif of this type of
movie
and which is exactly the right thing to
do and i liked the chara
like the the characters were likable
yeah they made everybody likeable
everybody's likable yeah
um you know what i mean but and and the
humor was good but not
you know because sometimes you see
action movies and you can try hi i'm the
comic relief character and they're like
all zany and wacky and everything
it's like in this one i think the humor
was better because it came more from
like situational
yeah and it was just kind of like an out
you know it was more like an outgrowth
of people's personalities rather than
hey i'm the i'm the stock funny guy yeah
you know i don't want to steal too much
of the movie's thunder
but part of this whole time travel
gimmick allows them
to recruit very unlikely people for this
and because they can't be selective
when it comes to recruitment yeah they
also cannot be very hard when it comes
to training
so they're basically just taking kind of
average people
and arming them and throwing them at
[ __ ] armies of aliens
yeah and that in itself causes a lot of
[ __ ] mayhem
yeah and the whole time travel [ __ ]
technology that they have doesn't really
work that well
so there's a bunch of bad side effects
that was another thing i liked about it
too was that everything was just because
everything had happened so quickly
like everything was just kind of like
cash together like at the last minute
which probably would be what really
happened so there's [ __ ] ups and it's
like and i like that
i don't this isn't really spoiling
anything i like that
it was like no one's fault really yeah
it's just everybody was just trying to
do the best they could do
right you know what i mean and it just
like wasn't good enough yeah you got to
take certain kinds of people between
certain age
brackets i want to steal the movies
thunder
but there's no time to they they teach
them how
to operate a weapon and how to shoot
them how to shoot but there's no
tactical training or unit training or
anything like that well because they're
in a timeline
yeah they're just basically like look
just go in there and like see that it's
just like shoot at them they're trying
to recruit
they're recruiting large swaths of the
population
quickly and just throwing them into the
future to fight these things
and it allows for a bunch of unlikely
people
in a combat situation getting [ __ ] up
some of them
some of them do pretty well some of them
are veterans
from other wars that do well other ones
are just people that don't belong there
yeah they don't belong there at all and
which kind of added another element
to it you have people who are
non-fighters trying to fight
yeah you know and like i said some of
the humor comes from that
because yeah right you know but but they
don't overplay it which i liked
you know what i mean it was more like
it's funny but it's more like realistic
like you you throw these people into
this situation that no one's ever been
in before
and they don't really know what they're
doing no i don't know anything and um
you know what i mean but they're trying
but they still can't really do it
because they you know what i mean it was
the only way you could have scenes like
that where you have people that don't
belong there heavily armed fighting
aliens
i mean that one scene was like the one
guy running on the step shooter they
only go
like all the way down really hard yeah
so i'm like yep that'd be me there's one
part where it kind of homages
um i think uh video game
uh the one where the uh [ __ ] was one of
the mercenaries the diamond dogs
they were out there living on that damn
halo what no
um the other one [ __ ] uh
metal gear socks kind of like metal gear
where they're
they're the the the time machines are on
these
oil platforms these big oil rigs that
they put they're pretty vast
and it's got its own defense defensive
perimeters and a bunch of weapons
and in one scene whole hordes whole
army hordes of these aliens are
attacking it
and they can swim you just gotta see
it's pretty cool
they can also glide yeah they pull that
out of their ass real quick quick too
they glide like a gl
like a gliding squirrel or like a flying
squirrel
it's all kinds of things that they can
do yeah i mean the thing about like i
i really like this movie seemed like
i don't want to say it seemed like a
throwback to like 80s or 90s action
movies it does have an
element of that but it still seems very
much like a modern movie to me you know
what i mean
it seemed like it was a good yeah it
seemed like it was a good combo
yeah of those two things in terms of in
terms of just the way it looked and
quality and everything and what kind of
movie it is
in some ways it's kind of like those new
godzilla and king kong movies
yeah where every the scale is very large
you see really like big buildings and
big battlefields and then
little guys are fighting it inside and
outside
jets and [ __ ] it just seems kind of like
one of the like one of the new
godzilla movies kind of i like that they
shot a lot of this on location and they
didn't just do cgi in the backgrounds
because there's
there's one part toward the end which
takes place in like an arctic sort of
landscape
yeah and i kind of feel like a lot of
cheaper movies would have just like done
all it
in cgi but they didn't they actually
shot that in iceland i think yes and
there's like a little bit of an homage
to uh to the thing the thing is series
going on there they knew exactly what
they're doing
yeah like i said they weren't trying to
reinvent the wheel they were just saying
like things that worked from those types
of movies yeah
let's make just like a fun entertaining
yeah
sci-fi action movie that's you know
that's lovingly tributing this and it's
obvious that they saw those movies and
they know that you saw those movies
so that's what that's what they're doing
which i think was
i think that's i think the director and
the way the script was written and the
way they executed i think it was spot on
i think that was the best way to do it
this is this is one had it been in the
theater
without all this [ __ ] that's
happened recently this would have done
well in the theater
i think it probably would have i guess
they just weren't they weren't confident
that there would be enough
uh of a theater you know uh enough
people going to the theater to make the
money back so they just like let amazon
have it
i think it would have done about like
what skull island did yeah in the
theater about like that which that i
think it did that did pretty good
the director of this was actually the
same guy that did the lego batman movie
okay that was a good movie
which uh it was fun we saw that one yeah
that was fun so um you know i don't
think he's done like a [ __ ] ton of other
movies but
we didn't see lego no we didn't see lego
batman we saw batman was in a movie that
we saw
yeah but lego batman has his has his own
movie yeah i haven't seen him
we saw just the lego movie this actually
i
yeah we saw the lego movie in like the
second part yeah
we saw those but i don't think i ever
saw the lego batman move
the solo lego batman movie although i
heard it was like excellent
some people have said it was like the
best batman movie ever
i kind of do want to see it because i
i'm really entertained by those like
movies i don't know what it is
yeah especially if you had a few drinks
well
well that kind of is true of anything
but yeah see i didn't even need a drink
for this last night the only thing i
will
um i was gonna say i thought it was
slightly long
but now that i'm thinking about it i
don't think that really bothered me that
much we were sitting at home
so it didn't matter that it was long
yeah so i think it's like two hours and
40 minutes or something like that which
is really that had we've been in the
theater
sitting in somebody else's seats you
don't talk about in those damn upright
seats that probably would have
been kind of a pain in the ass to be
there in almost three hours but at home
it plays
well i mean you could pause it go yeah
take a leak whatever because one thing
that i thought was interesting was that
you get i mean there's a lot of really
really big great like action set pieces
like battles and stuff with them like
fighting the aliens like in all
different uh
you know elements different locations
and i thought that was really well done
there's like different missions they go
on
and then it's interesting because
there's one like i said i'm not gonna
spoil it but almost like the big climax
part
and you kind of think that's the end but
then there's like a whole
other sequence and like a whole other
mission that they have to do
well because it didn't come out in the
theater they weren't worried about the
time
they know that you're gonna pause it
well and the thing too
is that avengers movies are [ __ ]
three hours long so obviously that's not
a detriment
three hour three hours is fine for a
movie that's streaming at home and you
can tell a more complete story and
people are they're used to binging
[ __ ] these series anyway well yeah
[ __ ] man so it's not as much of a hassle
when you're at your own house
i think that's the way they're going to
be from here on out really and i still
want to rent
the new i want to rent the new godzilla
movie but it's not up for rent or i
don't think yet i think they're still
selling it on
selling it on uh digital download for
[ __ ] 40 bucks last time i was i'm
gonna pay 40 bucks
well you just got to wait a few weeks
and then and then it'll come down to
like
i just want to rent 9.99 or something if
i want to buy it i don't want a digital
copy i want a [ __ ] blu-ray hard copy
of that [ __ ] man
grant there's hammer said my kids love
lego batman you have to check it out
what was funny is that when jenny and i
had um
had uh that emc what was that program
that we were on
subs yeah yeah on the stubs program
which was a good app
on your phone and you could see what
movie you want to see you can
reserve a seat just walk in and you can
see three movies a week wouldn't it
three
yeah three movies a week and it only
cost you 20 bucks a month
and that that was that was uh that was
that that was totally what i liked it
yeah i didn't see but we noticed that a
lot of the movies sucked
i mean a lot of movies sucked but the
kids movies were
tended to be better than a lot of the
[ __ ] adult movies i mean some of the
some of the adult movies were good but
remember when we saw like uh
the uh the dr seuss movie that was fun
um oh yeah the christmas the christmas
one i actually yeah i actually kind of
like that
then they had like i said it was a legos
movie and then there was something about
where they were all living inside a damn
computer
ralph breaks the entertainment that was
wreck-it ralph too yeah actually you
should probably see wreck-it ralph 1
because everybody thinks that one was
like way better
like the first one and then uh but the
the kids movies
tended to be more fun to watch and also
we saw a toy story four
yeah which was also good and they had uh
they had a bunch of uh
like hidden jokes and innuendos in there
because you know adults are [ __ ]
have written this thing and they know
that they don't they're trying to keep
the parents from getting bored yeah
so they're they're [ __ ] saying [ __ ]
on the slick
[Laughter]
like slight sexual innuendos every now
and then you're like going okay i got
you bro
well i kind of feel like well that's
kind of happening with kids movies going
back ages because and for exactly that
reason adults are making these
right and it's like you know you can't
just look fun to the adult yeah you
can't make
[ __ ] for children your whole entire life
when you're an adult or you'll go
insane so you have to kind of put some
[ __ ] in there and plus like you said you
know parents are taking their kids to
see this stuff so yeah you got to
keep them happy too so you got to keep
the parents happy too so they're not
just like sitting there but they're
brainstorming
we saw an ad uh an adams family too when
they're in
his family and i didn't love that but it
was it was pretty good i mean for that
for the adams family i really really
liked the live-action ones with uh
raul julie and angelica houston you know
back going back today the animated one
was okay
i liked that they went back to the the
original character designs from the
cartoon
like from the um you know from the
comics yeah um i liked that but i didn't
the story was a little yeah another good
kids movie that we saw was that the
house with the clock on its walls that
was pretty good
i was well i was super excited to see
that because
that was one of that was easily my
favorite book a jack black
as a kid and i had been wanting somebody
to make a movie out of it for like
[ __ ] ages
yeah it was actually pretty close to the
to the book i mean it was probably the
best um you know the best adaptation i
could have hoped for i wanted to make a
movie of day of the ness
yeah i remember you telling me before
yeah
little kids trying to foil an alien
invasion all the aliens have been
living underneath the ground for
centuries and they're emerging they come
and they look like a rock with legs and
[ __ ] and they had different classes of
them and
they're trying to reconquer the earth
that's pretty good and a couple people
are also recommending despicable me
uh i saw the first one and the first one
is excellent i agree
um but yeah so i haven't seen any of the
sequels though yeah you might like that
too as far as like animated kids movies
go
that's where that's where the minions
come from you know the little yellow
that's where they came from despicable
me but uh no i give i give the movie my
approval
yeah i mean i thought it was super
entertaining yeah grandfather says does
marilyn
kick some ass she should just do the
pouty face okay look
mary lynn always had that damn pouty
face even going on she does a lot of
pouty faces yes
yeah she and when she was a kid she just
would sit there with that [ __ ] pout
she's cute she's still got a [ __ ]
cute little figure and everything
um but yeah i think she's got kids of
her own now
but that's who she is even though she's
playing another character she's playing
kind of like a
kind of like a tough kind of [ __ ]
trucker kind of [ __ ]
yeah what was going on with her with her
hair in this movie
that's not how she actually looks well i
know but it's like it was just like
really funny
but i'm sorry just some rando chick just
random you know
and yeah she kicks ass she's got a
[ __ ] gun she's [ __ ] shooting she
goes out
she gets killed uh but she goes out like
a beast yeah she gets killed yeah she
goes out like a g
yeah it's all right yeah another thing i
wanted to mention too because we started
watching this
last night and i said i don't know
because i haven't finished watching it
yet cause it's a series and i didn't
want to do like a whole review on it
because it's not a movie
but i did want to mention it um there
used to be well it
used to be he's still around there's a
guy that had a youtube channel
right and his name was dame drops i
don't know if you guys know who he is
he started out reviewing fast food
he would just basically sit in his car
in the parking lot
of the fast food restaurant and would
review and he was funny as [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah and it's like so we used to watch
them all the time so every time like a
fast food restaurant
like got a new sandwich or whatever he
would go and try it out and then he
would be sitting in his car like filming
himself like eating it
and he's just like so so so funny he got
his
own netflix show yeah and it's called uh
fresh fried and crispy yeah it's good on
netflix yeah and each one and the
the uh episodes are pretty short they're
only like 28 minutes or something and
each one he goes to a different city
around the us and then he goes to like
three or four different restaurants and
each one and like tries out like their
fried
stuff and uh and does his dame drops
thing
yeah um but yeah so it's really really
good so if you haven't watched it it's
really funny he's just like he seems
like
he would be a delightful person to hang
out with yeah granters to answer your
question they all handed them out
like ar-15s they look like 11 and a half
inch barrel ar-15s with like
furniture from the future on them you
know plastic furniture
telescopic scope uh telescopic butt and
all that [ __ ]
crazy optics yeah i know she had a
telescopic butt yeah right here
red dots on the top and then [ __ ] you
know what i mean the little sideways
actually the sideways illuminated
[ __ ] sights on the
side and a [ __ ] scope on the top and
like you know how you know how they do
in the movies they just put every
[ __ ] thing on the damn weapon well it
looks cool though
yeah and um they're five five six
and uh they don't do much to these
aliens it's it's like i said it's kind
of like
uh it's kind of like out of battle
with battleship trooper troopers you can
sit there and [ __ ] empty a whole mag
into them and they're all right
you pretty much have to you pretty much
have to blow their heads right off
so i don't think nine millimeter do much
to one although a guy
one guy who was like a veteran at it was
using a shotgun
it looked like a remington 870 pump
shotgun
i think it was might have been it might
have been an automatic i think it might
have been a ram it might have been an
1100
i might have been on semi-auto actually
but it was just old like police shotgun
and that was that was working a lot
better on
close range yeah you have to get kind of
close though and you got to watch
because they have those [ __ ]
yeah they got spikes and tentacles
spikes and tentacles and uh and i
i was led to it so i wasn't sure if this
was like super clear but if you got hit
by one of the spikes
that would what like i assumed it was
poisonous i thought it was poison
yeah you know what i mean because as
soon as they got hit they acted like
they were a goner they're like oh [ __ ]
yeah so much for me then yeah because
i'm assuming that that's kind of like
what the aliens would they'd shoot you
with the with the little spike and then
that would poison you and then you go
unconscious and they dragged you
we only had two of those spikes because
i think they had to regrow
oh yeah i guess so yeah i was just
wondering about it
it's not it looks like a tail but they
they also
that's a tail at a tentacle same thing
and it's got like a hand that opens up
and there's
spikes in there yeah
funny face it looks like skull look the
face looks like general grievous
face and then except like i liked all
the teeth sticking out
i was into that kind of looked like the
dogs the dogs the alien dogs from what
predators they kind of looked like oh
yeah they kind of did they were white a
bit a lot bigger
they had six legs yeah and like you said
they just had six legs too on them
though wait did they i
can't remember yeah how long's the bench
that i've seen foreign
all right well you know i feel bad
because a couple people have just got
here
you have to watch it you have stuff in
the beginning
but yeah this was totally uh much better
than i expected actually
yeah i mean i was expecting it to be
like decent and entertaining but i
thought it was like really entertaining
it was like top shelf action movie yeah
like i said
i think i i definitely liked it better
than independence day
yeah i think the story was better
although i liked the whole idea of the
big
alien ship you know just yeah that was
cool but you don't know anything about
these aliens but
the the final sequence of it you start
finding more about them
which like i said i i liked that they
resolved that because that was one thing
we were going through you know because
like i said it's kind of a long movie
and as we're going through and i'm just
like are we just going to find out like
what is going on like where these aliens
like came from and
yeah what's because because they didn't
know like the characters in the movie
nobody really knew nobody knew
so they had to kind of like figure it
out as they went along and i liked
the i liked how they resolved that yeah
they know when they appeared but they
don't know how they got here
right yeah they said they just seemed
like they suddenly showed up someplace
yeah
and then started taking over the earth
because they eat people and they
reproduce like really really fast
yeah but they didn't it was well because
we were saying this like
pretty soon into the movie we're like
well these don't seem like the type of
aliens that would have
technology or like a ship or anything so
i said i wonder are they gonna like
sort that out or are they to tell us or
they're just going to be like i don't
know they just showed up here one day we
don't know they eventually tell you what
to do but they do yeah you do find out
like where they came from and like i
said i really like the way they
they uh resolved it yeah and it's all
real familiar when you say you go okay
yeah well yeah that's what i mean it's
like i think that's kind of why some
critics were like oh you know we're
doing this again but i was just kind of
like i
that didn't bother me though no it
didn't bother me though they were giving
the audience what they wanted
and to be honest there are only so many
things you like a story like that there
are only so many avenues you can go down
right that are that sound plausible you
can't just start pulling stuff out of
your ass because people just be like no
that's not how that would work
right so you know i mean the reason that
you keep seeing the same tropes over and
over is because they work or
people buy them you know what i mean so
so i so i didn't have any i
i liked the way they sorted it out i'm
just saying all right
so uh i guess we'll be back tomorrow
talking about another movie
uh i'm not sure which one we're gonna do
we'll find one i have some ideas but
we'll watch one tonight and then we'll
come back tomorrow and talk about it
so thanks everybody for dropping by and
we will see you guys tomorrow afternoon
bye